well connecting the rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and the Falcon in the Winter
Soldier looks to be setting up the
future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in a big with a big theme added question
of who will carry caps shield we did dig
deep into this mystery in the recent
episode of the big question
and now newer details are coming out
about who the next cap could be even
beyond Falcon as Avengers endgame would
lead us to believe like based on how
much Sam is discus tossing that thing
into trees does he really want it I mean
I'm just asking possible spoilers ahead
because I know how many of you feel
about over sharing social media posts
and set leaks but recently
Bucky actors Sebastian Spann shared on
social media a photo of himself with
Falcon actor Anthony Mackie Wyatt
Russell who will play u.s. agent John
Walker in the series and a fourth
mystery man let's break down all the
clues we could squeeze out of this post
with another new actor this guy has been
identified as actor Clay Bennett whom
you may know from the TIC the man in the
high castle the movie jigsaw his role
has not been confirmed but if you look
closely all these guys are wearing heavy
winter coats over their superhero
costumes Russell's got that u.s. agent
calf costume that he was seen wearing
the teaser footage at the football game
Mackey's got on his Falcon booties then
it has the faintest outline of a star on
his chest and to many this confirms yet
another cap related character could be
joining this cast Battlestar Lamarr
Hoskins saddle star has been rumoured to
be in the Falcon the Winter Soldier for
some time now ever since some set photos
circulated showing a van and storefront
with the business name Hoskins family
flowers now sometimes these details are
just thrown in as mere Easter eggs where
the production designers to reference
names from the comics coming now we're
seeing a fairly established actor
alongside the other stars with battle
stars iconic insignia and it's now
looking very likely that he's gonna be a
key player perhaps a new Avenger in the
MCU
so who is Battlestar well Lamarr Hoskins
was introduced alongside John Walker
when he was then known as super Patriot
Hoskins was given superhuman strength by
dr. Karl Malus on behalf of the power
broker Walker and Hoskins were part of a
group called the bold urban commandos
they ka the Bucky's attempting to get
her name out there with flashy heroic
feats trying to get the attention of the
US government and it kind of works
Walker becomes the sort of replacement
Captain America but Hoskins ends up
parting ways with him doesn't want to be
Walker's second fiddle anymore and takes
on a new name of Battlestar becomes a
hero in his own right actually later
carries a cap s atom
'i'm shield Bennett's battlestar they
play a similar role in this series
starting as part of John Walker's group
of wannabes while working in this
family's florist but then ascending as
Walker is made a star by the government
hoping to replace Steve Rogers not
really acknowledging Sam Wilson as the
rightful successor and other step photos
are showing u.s. army propaganda
proclaiming cap is back with John Walker
as the literal poster boy and so to
answer the query we explored in the big
question episode I believe these falcon
Winter Soldier episodes will focus on
Sam Wilson struggle to carry caps legacy
because well I think Sam is certainly
worthy of the shield he's already an
Avenger with his own identity he's
Falcon he can be capped for a time but
he should probably go back to being
Falcon by the end of the season so that
tells me that these episodes will be
seeking a new successor to the shield
beyond falcon someone who doesn't
already have an identity a fresh new
face well I will admit that I don't wake
up every day with this face being that
fresh especially after a long night of
piecing together clues or marble set
photos and Instagram posts big help with
waking me up so that I can yell the
stuff at you is bang energy and thanks
to bang energy for sponsoring this video
this can of Bang is a 15-ounce can of
heavenly hazelnut it's a coffee flavor
in addition having 300 milligrams of
caffeine it's also got 20 grams of
protein and and yeah it tastes great
like with this I'm not gonna wait in the
drive-through for my coffee place ever
again got a nice sweet coffee flavor and
I'm ready to go but in addition to
heavenly hazelnuts there are 20
different flavors to choose from
check out bang on Instagram you can get
25% off your order at bang - energy calm
when you use the code new rock stars 25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and Miami cool
app Purple Haze you can also get
clothing fitness supplements all kinds
of stuff to be your best bang self
thanks again a bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25% off at
bang - energy comm using the code new
rock stars 25 and hey follow the
inventor of bang on instagram at bang
energy CEO so who could be the new cat
face by the end of Falcon where soldier
well it could be a Clay Bennett as
battle star but it could also be someone
none of the footage or set photos or
social media posts have shown us to me
the big clue remains the casting of Carl
lumber on the show now umbly could
simply be playing a family member of Sam
Wilson or Lamarr Hoskins or an
interesting casting choice could be
Isiah Bradley the original black Captain
America actually went into Isiah
Bradley's history
more in the big question but really I
don't think Marvel would have Sam hand
off the shield to an older dude instead
I could see Isaiah as a mentor figure a
past retired unknown cat from an erased
history who counsels Sam about what it's
like when your own government ignores
your talents and sacrifices and replaces
you with a fraud whom they prefer to
slap on their posters builds mitt lesson
that Sam could learn would be that he
never really wanted to be Captain
America anyway he wants to be Falcon but
he also wants to honor Steve Rogers
legacy and make sure the shield ends up
in the right hands I suspect those right
hands will be either those a Battlestar
or an even fresher face we haven't seen
a promising young man
Isaiah's grandson Elijah Bradley Elijah
Bradley is patriot from a young Avengers
comics alongside iron lad ho clean
Wiccan stature Cassie Lang and Hawkeye
Kate bishop Patriots a team leader he
claimed to have superpowers from his
grandpa but actually was using the
mutant growth hormone but he goes clean
and continues to fight alongside the
Young Avengers is a naturally agile and
athletic tactical commander now we do
know Disney Plus will introduce Hailee
Steinfeld Kate Bishop in the Hawkeye
series and perhaps Wiccan in the one
division series we've speculated
theories that the announced ant-man 3
could feature the aged up Cassie Lang
from Avengers in game as stature and
we've talked about iron lad and our
theories about Kang the Conqueror and
Loki since you know they're technically
the same person while others have
suggested iron lad tight successors with
ty simpkins as Harley keiner or
Katherine Linc bird as Morgan Stark
both of whom also appeared an endgame if
the Falcon Winter Soldier were to
introduce the Bradley family tree -
could be established as the future
Patriot who inherits the shield by the
season finale who do you think should
carry caps shield next join this
conversation on our official discord
channel where we share our Marvel
unfiltered hot takes access our discord
by becoming a patron of new rock stars
today at patreon.com slash new rock
stars like this video share it around
and subscribed into rock stars for more
of our Marvel theories thanks for
watching bye
[Music]